okay today I'm going to talk to you
about biotic and abiotic factors what
these are are different factors that can
affect the population of a particular
species within a habitat so to begin
with I'm going to talk to you about
biotic factors now the prefixed bio
means living so biotic factors are
living things that can change in alter
the population of other living things so
we're going to have a look at two
different aspects of this so first of
all we're going to look at this thing
called competition now a nice
illustration of this is with squirrels
there's two types of squirrel that still
live them in the UK the red squirrel and
the grey squirrel now they used to be
many many more red squirrels living
across the UK but in about the 1800s the
grey squirrels were introduced to the UK
now they were both competing for the
same resources for the same food for
example now the grey squirrels being
somewhat stronger and bigger out
competed the red squirrels so the
introduction of this these grey
squirrels a biotic factor because the
grey squirrels are living it affected
the population of the red squirrels so
competition is a really good example of
an alteration in a biotic factor the
changing of a biotic factor another key
point is predators another biotic factor
that could be introduced so imagine
let's say we have both of these
squirrels coexist in if we were to
introduce a predator such as this Fox
here again it's a biotic factor because
it's a living thing it would alter the
numbers of these squirrels because the
frogs could prey on these squirrels so
the number of squirrels the population
could decrease so again we're looking at
a biotic factor the other type of
factors that we're going to look at are
abiotic factors now these are the
nonliving things that could alter the
population of an organism within an eco
so there's four things that we're going
to look at number one is temperature so
remember temperature is abiotic because
temperature is obviously nonliving so
I'm just going to draw a quick picture
of a thermometer so essentially
different animals and plants thrive best
at different temperatures some would
thrive best in higher temperatures some
thrive fest in lower temperatures so the
temperature can have an effect on the
distribution of organisms within an
ecosystem the next fire factor abiotic
again because it's nonliving is water so
the the amount of water can massively
influence the distribution of organisms
for example daisies grow best in soils
that are slightly damp so if there's if
there's too much water or it's too dry
will have no daisies whatsoever and
that's just one illustration of how
water affects the distribution of
organisms let's say there's a drought if
there's very little water at all
there'll be very few plants growing
whatsoever because plants require water
in order to photosynthesize so those are
to a buttock factors the next one is
light intensity so how much light there
is available within an ecosystem so this
can also massively influence the
distribution of organisms for example
certain certain things like fungi and
mosses grow best in dark conditions so
whereas things like grasses may be
better in lighter conditions so the
light intensity again abiotic is
nonliving massively affects the
population of different organisms and
finally the last one we're going to look
at is pollutants and here's just a
little power plant I'll draw here
okay so pollutants can also affect the
population of diff
species for example sulfur dioxide so2
can mean that certain things called
lichens it affects the growth of certain
organisms called lichens which means
they can't grow you can actually learn
more about this in the video about
indicator species but again if we have
certain pollutants it might cause a
decrease in certain organisms or in the
case of eutrophication again in another
video we can see that pollutants can
actually increase the growth or coverage
the growth of plants like algae so just
to summarize there's two types of
factors biotic and abiotic biotic a
living so if animals compete against
each other they can affect each other's
population if we introduce predators it
can again cause a decrease in the
population of the prey the for abiotic
factors you need to know a temperature
water light intensity and pollutants and
all four of these can also influence the
distribution and population of organisms
within an ecosystem thank you